so hi uh my name is David Audra uh I'm a
member of the solutions engineering team
at posit and the world's worst Kelly
o'briant
impersonator uh and with that said let's
talk about
connect um so I like to think about
deploying things to connect as a magic
trick not magic uh in this house we
respect the laws of phys physics uh and
computers large language models
notwithstanding are deterministic uh but
as a magic trick uh in the taxonomy uh
proposed by a particular Christopher
Nolan movie um a trick comes in three
phases the first is the Pledge I show
you something you've seen before I
encourage you to inspect it I tell you
that it's ordinary it's a shiny app that
runs at extraordinary Zoom uh on your
laptop or alternatively it's a shiny app
built in Python which I guess is a
little bit more novel
uh that runs again on your laptop I
encourage you to look at the shiny app
if it was cooler in here I would remove
my jacket or warmer in here I would
remove my jacket there's nothing off my
sleeves the second phase of the trick
is called the turn and in the turn you
begin to
suspect that something about this is not
ordinary and so that's the wrong app
hoay for command history
but uh I'm going to
deploy this shiny
app or I could jump
over to the the IDE and publish this
application and so I'm showing you now
you know a bunch of logs um something is
clearly happening it's not clear what uh
but a bunch of logs does not really make
a magic trick
right I can't just make the app
disappear it has to go somewhere else
and
so that's that's where we get to the
third phase of the trick the hardest
part right where I make the app reappear
on connect and we call that part The
Prestige it's a great movie you should
see it
um but in this case the trick is not
actually that the app is running on
connect the
trick and I'm typing super fast right
now is that the app is running in a
container okay and so now uh like any
magician uh what I will do is I'm going
to take you behind the trick uh and then
we'll talk a little bit about whether
this is a thing you should try at home
okay so to begin let's talk let's start
by talking about connect right what is
connect connect I think um I like to try
to Define things by like what they do
and what connect does is it drives down
the cost of application publishing I
think people at this conference are
probably pretty used to the idea uh that
data scientists or people who in the
course of doing their work build web
applications uh but that's not a typical
view that most people hold about one of
the things that data science is um and
so part of what connect does is it makes
it easy for data scientists to get work
off their machines by reducing the
demands on what it asks them for uh when
they're trying to publish something
right so connect deployments do lots of
work to inspect your local environment
um gather up some information about what
you have there and then send that to the
server where connect reconstructs the
environment for you um and connect
servers and I have you know one of those
architecture diagrams that James pulled
up before right a single connect server
can run multiple versions of R multiple
versions of python multiple versions of
quto it can handle conflicting versions
of packages for each of those runtimes
um and it deploys the applications in an
isolation an atomic way right so it
makes it again it's trivial to publish a
new thing if you break it you just
publish again you roll forward you
iterate you make progress and for most
many workflows um that's good
enough there are however circumstances
where uh more complexity is required
right that might be because you're
working with packages that um are for
some reason difficult to install right
they might have complicated dependencies
uh that are difficult for something
running at the application layer uh to
reconstruct there might be conflicting
package dependencies you might have data
that's stored in uh you might have data
that's stored somewhere that demands
something else about the way you access
that data right so the Linux file system
is is no longer enough um and so for for
all of those reasons right we've put a
lot of work into uh making it possible
to run connect right in kubernetes right
we've decoupled where connect runs and
where applications run applications sit
in their own container context um and
connect is responsible for spawning them
and managing some other things right and
we call this mode offhost execution um
and so what I want to do now is I want
to show you around some of the connect
interfaces that reflect this change uh
so that you can understand what kinds of
things are possible when connect is
running in this modee so I'll jump back
to our shiny application here and if you
look at the right side you'll see that
you know below the settings where we can
control uh the access to the application
or the sub path we serve it on we have
some additional configuration settings
and so in addition to controlling the
for example the user executing the
content we might also uh provide a
specific kubernetes service account
right which would have permissions to
access particular data sources in a way
that isn't going to sort of correspond
to how we do that in the Linux file
system and that's going to make it um
easier um to provide that fine grained
permissioning right the other the other
new uh sort of option you're seeing here
is the ability uh to configure execution
environments on a per deployment basis
and so what you're seeing here right is
I pushed a a container to the GitHub
container registry that just has a
version of python in it but I can change
that environment to be something uh more
complicated it might be the case that
for example I have uh an image that has
RN python in it and if I'm thinking
about making changes to my application I
can select a different image for
subsequent
execution right and I can also select
that as a default environment image if I
come back to the connect homepage you'll
see there's an additional tab that
explains the execution environments that
are available right and so in addition
to to the default images uh that connect
uh ships with in the helm chart I used
to provision this instance uh I've added
this uh this python 3.10 image uh and
also an image uh that has a version of
quto 1.4 in it uh I am extremely excited
about quto 1.4 uh and if you want to
understand why you should go to Carlos
sher's talk
um but that's not all right so in
addition to to wanting to say constrain
the environment that we're constructing
um as as connect is being built right
one of the other things we might need um
is the ability to control the resources
that are being consumed by the
application while it runs uh and so uh
in addition to uh memory limits which
you can apply now in both local and
offhost exe execution mode uh you can
also apply CPU limits and this means
that if you have applications that have
a way of spinning out taking down
servers and forcing you to buy people
beers uh you can put a little bit more
guard rails around that in a way that's
going to make uh your application safer
to
use and then the last thing and this is
one of the newest pieces of of
functionality that we've introduced to
connect uh is the ability to bypass uh
certain elements of environment
reconstruction uh you can see here on
both the r environment and python
environment management we have the
option to select the uh a set
which gives us control over who has
responsibility for environment
construction so I pushed a container
that has just a python image in it and
so I allowed connects to build the
content in my container it's also the
case that I could construct an
environment that has um all of the
dependencies that my application
requires and then push that container to
connect without with uh and connect
doesn't have to actually do that app the
environment restoration step um and so
that's giving you again
more fine grained control over what
exactly is executing and where um so
that's a I think a quick overview of
some of the things that we've changed
about connect uh to to make it a better
citizen in kubernetes um and I think
I'll stop there and take any questions
that anyone
[Applause]
has thank you David um the first
question question I have here reads can
we also run connect work workloads in
the slurm cluster in the future to match
workbench so that's an excellent
question one thing I I would say on the
on the question of mashing workbench
right is that uh if you're running
workbench in an off house execution mode
uh there's some documentation we're
polishing on this now but one of the
things people often want to do is take
the container image they've defined for
workbench and then pull that over to
connect and use it right it's not
necessarily the fastest way to that but
it gives you a very clear idea about
what's executing here and here uh and so
that is definitely something you can do
currently uh we are still thinking about
other venues for sort of uh this
distributed execution model um let's
chat later about your interest in
slur thank you all right the next one
says um is there a way to speed up the
launch of content of PODS when they're
open takes a few seconds longer than i'
like some of that will I think uh yeah I
I believe that an option where more of
the
um more where if you have essentially if
you bake the content into the image um
then you will bypass some of the steps
that increase the startup time in
off-host execution mode um so that that
might be one way uh to to think about
increasing the startup time if you're
concerned about that thank you all right
so the next one says um
um sorry they're moving around here me
um on the single server instance we
normally P patch the server uh for
example a AP get and the content would
not be affected can I patch execution
images without
worry can you patch execution
IM
I that's an interesting I suppose you
could patch the image but I wouldn't
guess re build the image yeah I just I
would just build a new I would build I I
would think about that as an opportunity
to build and publish a new image yeah
sense yep um all right so do you find uh
that some of your clients want more
control of the resources that connect
apps or apis consume similarly of how
our studio on sag Maker
Works so the I think some of the um
settings that I showed on the on in the
runtime panel give you a little bit more
control over the maximum CPU and memory
that applications will consume uh so
that's one limit you can impose the life
cycle is a bit different to Sag maker
because you're starting each um each
sagemaker instance is is essentially its
own its own ec2 instance whereas these
are typically pods that are running on a
on a node and so I think it's slightly
different but you get to control things
in either way
okay um let's see here make sure in time
here nothing think um so what is
handling the workload resources for say
uh fractional CPU course or memory is
connect communicating with the quetes
engine or changing not pool specs uh so
connect embeds the the service uh if
you've heard people talk about the
launcher Service uh it's responsible for
communicating with the kubernetes API
makes sense all right um next one says
um is there a case where one can use
kubernetes and open a shiny server
perhaps for local pot-based testing
without Ingress or aggress Consequences
on connect in a
cloud
I I'm trying to to par some one could
could you one more I just want to make
let's do it again all right let's try it
again let's see is there a case when
where one can use kubernetes and the
open shiny server perhaps for local
pod-based testing without Ingress and
eress consequences on connecting the
cloud so I guess if you want to testour
yeah
you you certainly could I think there's
a it's kind of a philosophy of testing
question and at that point I'm not sure
what you would be
testing um can you elaborate on baking
content to speed up content launches
very interesting
proposition uh I will um in the place
where I get to dump notes for this talk
I will put a the link to there's a or I
guess I can just pull it up here um
there is a reference in the connect API
cookbook um that illustrates some of the
workflow I'm
describing um and so if you have uh it's
it's in the cookbook under custom
execution environments uh I'll if you if
you're very curious about that you can
email me at David atos it.co and I'll
send it to
you all right so um can I build
arbitrary content in an image and then
have a coasted posit connect on
kubernetes
yes I mean
well arbitrary is is is a large word but
that is that is the idea that was a very
brave response on your side I'm going to
eat that one
later they're going to send a recording
of this talk to to us say you if you
decide to put uh I don't know node in
there I don't don't expect to have a
good time but otherwise I think we'll be
okay so when you deploy an app to an
environment the packages the app uses
are baked into the Container image and
not a library directory mounted on a
shared
dis no so so the uh and I I all lighted
this because of the the magic medic 4
but the environment
restoration
um is happening on the the NFS uh
persistent volume that's attached to the
cluster and so the the concept that you
um you'll have seen in local execution
modes of connect um about the cache that
that mechanism is still preserved uh so
the the content is Tim is ultimately
associated with a uh a like a runtime
cache uh that you can uh sort of do
surgery on as
needed uh so how challenging will it be
to deploy from workbench instance
running on kubernetes to connect app
deployed on
kubernetes uh that's going to depend a
lot on what uh is going to depend a lot
on the environment right um an
application that doesn't have any
complicated uh dependencies like the
ones I deployed um you can see they're
they were running locally on my laptop I
deployed them into a cluster into a
container uh I didn't really have to do
anything to make that happen uh if you
have more complicated dependencies and
you might need to be a little bit more
thoughtful about how you uh describe uh
your desired deployment um both the RS
connect package and the python command
line interface uh provide ways for you
to select a specific image to execute
the content as long as that image is
known to the server uh and so uh you do
get a lot of flexibility there about
either deciding to let connects pick an
image for you or specifying one if
that's the the desired outcome thank you
um next question says uh can we specify
a base image for connect to build a
container
from I would not say right now that
connect builds
containers so you can specify an image
that you would like your R python
environment to be restored into
um let's see the next one says is there
a plan support for Cuda o nnx uh runtime
selection any GPU allocations and
deposit connect
UI uh there there is some work under way
to make it easier to select GPU
resources
yeah all right so I think that's the the
questions great um thank you so much uh
please um join me and thanking David
again thank you